hello everyone and welcome to a video or
maybe even a video series I don't think
I'll be able to do it in one setting um
uh how did we get uh here how do how do
we get where we are I don't mean us the
humans but uh you know us the chess
players how did we get uh from just
playing against the the other guy to
playing against the really strong
computers uh you know even in our Even
in our pocket we have uh uh an opponent
so strong that we can't even imagine of
beating we can't even imagine anyone in
the world eating um the computer so so
how did that uh come to be who who's
responsible for that and uh when when
did it all be began uh to to you know to
answer that we have to go back some well
not not not a century but a a little
less than that and there were attempts
throughout chess history to uh make
money and you know to uh impress people
with sort of uh chess chess mechanical
units everyone is uh familiar with the
mean Mechanical Turk uh where a strong
chess player would climb inside the
mechanical unit and uh well use the
mechanism to operate the machine and
then make the moves and you would of
course make money you would go to fairs
people would challenge The Mechanical
Turk and he would beat you at chess and
uh uh it's not really what we are
looking for here well it is actually a
mechanical unit moving the pieces it's
not the mechanical uh unit uh deciding
on the moves it's actually a human
inside the machine making the moves uh
but the first ever machine that was
created that um played the moves or
rather the first ever algorithm that was
created was turo champ uh devised by
none other than Alan touring here and
probably if you have heard of Alan
touring even just by you know going to
high school and maybe learning of the
touring test uh but um I've learned that
there's even a movie made uh about Alan
Turing and his life and you know his
assistance in in cracking the Enigma
code and U yeah it's actually very very
interesting but not the topic of this
video but I will give you a sorry a
brief um Insight on that so uh in 1938
uh he started the uh creating a a sort
of another mechanical unit similar to
the Polish bomba crypto now that was
used to uh decipher the Enigma code this
is the Enigma machine and um uh this was
used by by German soldiers in the field
um during the World War to encrypt and
decrypt messages and Communications so
while the Polish bomba Crypt was able of
deciphering those messages it was too
dependent on a mechanism uh that the the
Germans will easily uh change so it
wasn't really a long-term solution and
that's where Alan Turing comes in with
his team and he devises a similar uh
similar uh unit called The Bombay and
over the course of two years he really
um um he he really advances it and makes
it um very successful in cracking the
code and uh it's very useful I mean when
you have a you know it's it's World War
II you know if if you have a ship
carrying a lot of weapons or a lot of
food or even people you don't want that
ship intercepted so cracking cracking
code was definitely a big help but while
that story is fascinating in itself and
I haven't watched the movie yet I will I
I didn't want to spoil my video by
watching the movie first I don't know if
there's any chess in the movie I would
be very sad if they made a you know a
movie about the life of alen Turing
without including chess uh but you never
know you know all depends on whether the
the director is a chess fan or not uh
but that brings us uh to how Alan Turing
came about working on on chess and why
chess well chess is an incredible way uh
of uh figuring out can a computer
actually think for itself or give it
give give an impression of thinking
everyone is familiar with the famous
touring test uh uh it's you know used
everywhere uh where you have like U not
used everywhere but uh everyone knows
about it's like you have uh um one
person here and in the Next Room you
have like uh I don't know 10 people and
one of those 10 people is a machine and
then by asking questions you have to
figure out which one is the machine or
you have a sort of a a backwards touring
test where you're on internet and you
have capture tests and you have to prove
that you are a human being but um yeah
after the World War II he he got working
on um uh well on a lot of things and he
was very much interested in artificial
intelligence even though interestingly
uh the term artificial intelligence was
not coined for like two years after his
death he died in 1954 so probably 1956 I
have not checked this thoroughly but um
yeah I don't know if if the term
artificial intelligence was used back
then and um yeah he was working uh on a
uh sort of on the first program for the
first commercial ever computer the feran
Mark 1 or the Manchester Mark 1 uh and
he tried to uh Implement his chess
software or the the T chimp algorithm
into this computer but it was not
possible it was too too big and the well
the the fan Mark 1 was still too
primitive to receive such uh such a
noble code that is able um you know play
chess and it took him some two years to
devise the code and in 1952 after
failing to implement the code in the
first ever commercially available chess
playing computer uh he actually ran the
code with pen and paper against his
colleague in cooworker Alec Glenny here
who is uh amongst the people I believe
who have created the first ever compiler
Al although depending on what source you
go to also the first ever compiler was
created by US Navy officer Grace Hopper
uh and also Alec Glenny here created the
first auto code so depending on what
source you use uh they didn't know each
other they didn't you know use each
other's work they just independently
created the same thing basically only we
do not have any any leftovers or any
traces of a Grace's code so I believe
that's why Alec Glenn is considered the
first to create it but okay not really
relevant to this just thought I'd
mention it so let's check it out and uh
uh very important is that this game as
it was uh the algorithm was run by pen
and paper by Alan Turing himself uh took
uh several weeks to complete uh that's
uh that's uh I mean that's long uh but
it was very necessary because how how
did the algorithm assess the positions
to give you a a simplified explanation
it would uh for example first move it's
uh uh it's a tour Champs move and it has
to decide which move to make you have a
you know you have several options you
have to decide every each and every one
one of them and the algorithm in fact
did consider every possible move so he
considered A3 A4 B3 B4 C3 C4 D3 D4
Knight moves Knight F3 Knight A3 uh
Knight to F3 Knight to H3 uh sorry
Knight C3 Knight A3 uh so every possible
move was considered and then uh every
position after each of those moves was
uh attributed a certain amount of points
and the points were attributed to uh how
how well your pieces were protect ected
how mobile were your pieces for example
if you played H3 your Bishop uh Mobility
hasn't really increased but if you
played E3 the mobility of the bishop
definitely increases uh and thus that
position is granted more points and also
how vulnerable is your king how easy it
is to attack your opponent's king how uh
are you attacking any of your opponent's
pieces are you able to capture any of
your opponent's pieces so there are many
many steps to the algorithm and um
different points were attributed and I
believe this is the first time ever that
anyone attributed uh uh points to the
pieces um sort of to to evaluated the
position uh in in this particular manner
so you know give the pawn one point give
the Knight three points give the Rook
Five Points give the the queen 10 points
uh I don't know it was done before but
uh that that is the the point system
that was used also in evaluating the
position even though from experience now
you know that the queen sometimes worth
zero points uh sometimes it's worth uh
you know all the points that doesn't
really matter uh but in in a way to make
it simple for the for the algorithm to
make a move such a system was needed and
the way Alan Turing describes it it
wasn't going to play an incredible game
uh it will be it will use a heuristic
approach uh and it will make uh you know
a viable move it will it will not make
the greatest move but it's not going to
make the dumbest move either so let's
check it out this is um uh this story
Champs uh game against Ali Glenny Alan
touring's coworker and colleague let's
check it out Pawn to E4 by turo Champ
and makes sense this gives the bishop a
lot of Mobility so naturally the
position is given uh more points than
the other positions E5 Knight to C3 now
okay also watch TIN it said Knights go
into the game before Bishops uh Knight
to F6 and now Pawn to D4 the game was
played in 1952 also uh same year U that
that Allan touring died we have D4 and
Bishop to B4 now this move uh although
it makes sense from a human State
standpoint today it is a well-known
blunder uh because it's uh very easy to
exploit this D captures on E5 Knight
captures and queen G4 and already black
is in a lot of trouble even if you
capture let s C3 Queen captures here you
have to move back the Knight now Queen
G4 again attacks the pawn and if you
Castle then Bishop to H6 will put
pressure on G7 and if you just defend
the pawn this way then white gets gets
all of these developing moves in and
black is just in a terrible terrible
situation uh but okay uh turo champ was
unable to see that far Knight to F3 was
played we have D6 and now Bishop to D2
so just rapid development Knight to C6
and now uh Pawn to
D5 it's interesting that it uh uh gives
uh more points to advancing the pawn
sort of to grabbing more space uh
something that can be considered you
know a positional way of playing chess
then to capture on E5 even even though
okay it's just a trade we have Knight to
D4 putting pressure on the Knight and
pawn to H4 the first ever computer game
and pawn to H4 is played and even now
nowadays every computer just pushes that
pawn to H4 so Bishop to G4 and now look
at this Pawn to A4 uh probably the logic
the the the engine had or the algorithm
had that uh while the pawns were on H2
and A2 The Rook really isn't useful but
here I mean the Rook is controlling H2
H3 guarding H4 you are controlling G5
now you're controlling B5 uh you're
controlling a lot of squares and
controlling squares is definitely
something you should uh uh go for for
where when playing chess so okay Knight
captures on F3 with check G captures
Bishop to H5 and now Bishop to B5 with
check rapidly developing C6 and now D
captures on C6 we have castles and now C
captures on B7 Rook B8 and Bishop A6
defending the pass Pawn on B8 on B7 so
Queen A5 going after the bishop and
queen to E2 defending the bishop so you
can see that uh pretty much every move
is tailored towards just uh controlling
more squares uh Knight to D7 uh and now
we have Rook to G1 we have Knight to C5
Glenny also goes after that white king
now everything is here preparing for an
attack if the Rook mov moves you might
even consider capturing on C3 maybe
eliminating the A4 Pawn uh Rook to G5
attacking the bishop Bishop to G6 and
now Bishop to B5 uh interestingly Bishop
to C4 would have been much better just
stopping the F Pawn and preparing Pawn
to H5 but here Bishop to B5 was played
Knight captures on B7 and now Queens
side castles and now okay you don't wait
you will capture on C3 but first Knight
back to C5 Bishop to C6 now again Bishop
to C E4 was much better uh but um turo
champ seems to be more interested in
controlling more space by putting the
bishop on D5 also centralizing your
piece so Rook F to C8 and now Bishop to
D5 and while uh turo champ also operates
under the same principles that a modern
super engine does it just not as
powerful and doesn't see tactically far
enough to avoid certain moves Bishop
captures on C3 Bishop captures and queen
captures on A4 now uh and King to D2
again H5 is winning here for for Turan
but he goes King to D2 uh just you know
if we get our King over to the king side
we'll probably be safer uh now comes
Knight to E6 attacking the rook and The
Rook to
G4 uh Knight to D4 now putting pressure
on the queen even though Rook captures
on B2 is just crushing here uh turo
champ not able to see that because uh
well you just break through and there's
no defense here if Bishop captures then
you have the C2 Pawn hang
so Knight to D4 was played Alec finds a
similar idea again if the bishop moves
the C2 Pawn will be captured but now
there's Queen D3 and the game continues
we have Knight to B again Rook captures
on B2 by far the strongest H but he
misses that Knight to B5 Bishop to B3
and now Queen to A6 or like I said the
game was played over the course of the
few weeks so maybe he even considered
move and he found the line but then
after you know tur champ uh the found a
reply maybe he just forgot about it but
okay Bishop to C4 uh we have Bishop to
H5 and now Rook to G3 and here Queen to
A4 where white is again in a very very
strong um position here if Bishop to B3
is played and the queen moves then you
have all sorts of ideas Rook G5 attacks
the bishop now Bishop G6 will be met
with Pawn to H5 and G6 you can just
sacrifice The Rook uh and go Rook G1
check once the king moves F4 blasts open
the position and white will be winning
this uh but again to too far ahead for
turo champ Bishop captures on B5 was
played Queen captures on B5 and now uh
here I I I refuse to believe that uh
next move was played by by the algorithm
because there are many moves and we've
seen that the algorithm made some very
impressive moves here but you could
double up Rooks here nothing wrong with
that you could play King C1 improve the
the safety of your king the B2 Pawn is
nicely defended by the bishop uh you
could play Queen captures and B5 just
trade queens and play a nice calm game
but here instead Queen captures and D6
was played and uh okay if you're allowed
King to C1 your position is still great
but uh here the T Cham just ran into
Rook to d8 and he was in this position
un move 29 that t chimp resigned the
game so uh one possible thing is that
Turing was just uh you know fed up with
the game taking weeks and everything and
he said I mean let's just end the game
we've seen the the software works it
makes good moves you know it's
problematic for you to force your will
onto the damn thing let's just end the
game so I I think maybe that's why Queen
to D6 was played I don't I I can't
imagine that the same algorithm that
played this game uh okay maybe missed a
couple of uh moves where you had to C5
to six moves ahead but missing queen to
D6 I I I just don't buy it so uh that's
the game this is the first ever game
that was played by uh not a computer
software but by an algorithm
uh that was sort of written for the
fanti Mark 1 but was unable to run it
and the program never actually uh was
ran on a computer until and that's the
next game that we are going to show
until 2012 it was the Centenary uh of
the of the birth of Alan touring uh and
the software was finally ran on an
engine and there was an entire
exhibition where you could see a lot of
things from Alan turing's life uh and uh
the opponent for the for the chess
playing software was none other than
former world champion Gary Kasparov as
you uh Pro sorry as you as you might
have imagined I've accidentally shown
you uh so let's check it out and um uh
yeah it's uh very much different now
you've seen how the how the software
reacts at uh uh a lesser opponent Alex
Glenny but now we will see how it faces
off against uh well arguably one of the
strongest players uh to to ever play the
game uh Gary Kasparov so let's see Pawn
to E3 turo champ goes for the V Cru
opening and now Knight to F6 I don't
know the exact time the computer needed
to make the moves but I imagine it was
less than you know a few weeks for the
game Knight to C3 we have Pawn to D5
Kasparov strikes in the center and now
Knight to H3 trying to get Kasparov to
capture the the Knight but instead
Kasparov just grabs the full Center Pawn
to E5 and it wasn't the exact code that
Allan in head but it had to be recreated
the code was lost over the course of the
years uh so Queen to F3 going for some
incredibly rapid development Knight to
C6 and now Bishop to D3 so look at this
just incredible rapid development even
offering uh a piece uh for those two
Central pawns and Kasparov goes for it
E4 we have Bishop captures D captures
and Knight captures on e4 so uh eight
pawns to Champ six pawns Kasparov but
Kasparov is up a piece we have Bishop D
E7 Knight to G3 three and Kasparov just
castles uh castles by T champ as well
and Bishop to G4 now chasing away the
queen queen to F4 and now Bishop to D6
the queen has to move back Queen to C4
and now Kasparov just plays Bishop
captures on H3 D B uh G captures on H3
and queen to D7 kasparov's idea is of
course Queen captures on H3 Knight to G4
and queen to H2 Checkmate and with the
bishop uh nicely placed on this diagonal
it's hard to find a reputation
for this so Pawn to H4 was played again
with the pawn to H4 uh Queen to H3 and
now Pawn to B3 preparing to F to the the
dark Square Bishop but uh you know uh
there there's a chain saying you don't
play chess when your house is on fire
and uh wello chimp's house definitely is
on a fire cuar plays Knight to G4
threatening mate in one Rook to E1
making room for your king but it will
only prolong the game for one move Queen
captures on H2 was play King to one and
queen captures an F2 Checkmate uh and
that's how the game ended so it took
Alec Glenny 29 moves and that very very
you know questionable Queen captur on D6
move to take down turo champ uh but a
software that was run on P pen and paper
and it took Asar only 16 moves to take
down the software being run on an actual
computer and in 2012's computers were
were fairly you know fairly strong still
humans could beat the strongest tents uh
uh but yeah okay this was not the
strongest engine This was um this was
the first ever uh uh you know software
written for for a chess playing computer
at turo champ and Kasparov said that uh
well it's not the best but uh the
software did play a recognizable game of
chess and he said I suppose you might
call it primitive but I would compare it
to an early car you might laugh at it at
first but still an incredible
achievement so there we have it this is
the first time uh anyone not anyone
former world champion faced off against
the first ever uh code that was written
for a chess uh computer that was never
implemented on a chess computer like I
said as um Alan Turing was unable to
implement it on the fanti Mark 1 uh but
um uh yeah the first ever ever game
played by a computer or rather by a by
an algorithm is this one Alan Turing
versus Alec Glenny in 1952 was played in
Manchester where they worked and uh well
that is basically where our Journey
Begins so if you guys want to learn more
uh I'm I'm you know definitely up for uh
creating sort of a series where we go
from this game uh all the way to Alpha
zero Leela CH zero and modern neural
networks that we have nowadays to see
you know what kind of a journey it was I
could make it like a maybe 10 series
video or something like that uh if you
would like to uh to learn more uh but
yeah I think I I pretty much mentioned
everything that I wanted to probably I
forgot something important as I usually
do uh but you know feel free to to fill
me in in the comments if you have any
anything uh interesting on any of the
topics that I mentioned and also do
check out our our uh app for improving
it CH and will be the first link in the
description below and also parts of this
video will be uh will be uh you know uh
put in there in in little uh Snippets so
they're more easily digestible if you
guys enjoy that as well uh but yeah do
check it out we've improved it quite a
lot we've added a lot of stuff uh so you
know
uh G give me your give me your comments
on that as well uh and that's pretty
much it yeah that that's where our
journey begins with Alan Turing uh
someone who is not uh familiar for this
but rather for for breaking the Enigma
code uh but uh he was you know a very
very versatile man and uh well he he
also did a lot for for chess uh computer
chess uh so that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it a little bit of uh info
about Chess history and computer chess
history I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Caroline a and I would
like to thank Anna panovich Robert kefir
Welsh fan and Frank PL for her
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day